now thank you so much for joining us
here at 4 i'm kiersten joyce and i'm
christian casa as we begin this
afternoon with a snapshot of the
political state of play it is the first
look at polling from 8 news now emerson
college in the hill we asked about the
november election the president and
issues affecting our state well as
politics now host john langler explains
voters are unhappy and undecided
[Music]
four months it seems like a long time
but in politics the general election may
as well be tomorrow at this stage our
polling shows most major races are
relatively close the first question was
a simple one is the country headed in
the right direction our emerson college
8 news now the hill polling shows 55
percent say no but it's not as decisive
as it looks spencer kimball is with
emerson college which conducted the poll
you got to remember nationally only
about 20 percent of the country think
the country is headed in the right
direction so at least within the silver
states people are seeing a bit of a
silver lining that does not stretch to
president biden himself his approval
rating is down around 33 percent at the
same time 37 percent support the work of
the supreme court and governor steve
sisolak has a nearly 40 percent approval
rating that comes in handy since he's
running for re-election
right now sisilak leads his challenger
clark county sheriff joe lombardo by
about three points steve sebelius is
politics editor with the review journal
joe biden's numbers are so bad
he really has a huge deficit
to overcome and whether or not that
deficit is going to trickle down to
other candidates democratic candidates i
think is a legitimate question across
the poll kimball notices a trend lots of
undecided voters the number of undecided
voters this far out from election tells
us that there's a lot of campaigning
that's happening in the state currently
at this point it's pretty much even and
either party could go either way
tomorrow we will look at the senate and
congressional races we'll also examine
nationwide and statewide issues we
included in the poll john langler live
local now